I want to follow up the last video on
the sn2 ring opening of the cyclohexene
oxide because the way I explained it it
might have been a little non-intuitive
because when we first learned about sn2
and sn1 reactions we said well if you
have an a protic solvent with a okay
leaving group but a really good
nucleophile you'll have an sn2 reaction
but if you have a protic solvent if you
have a protic solvent with an excellent
leaving group
excellent excellent leaving group and a
weak nucleophile and a weak nucleophile
that that would lead you to an sn1
reaction and everything all of the
ingredients that I showed you in the
last video actually were more in this
direction we actually this was actually
an acid catalyzed reaction so it was
definitely protic and then this ring is
strained right here this epoxide ring
and we already protonated this this
oxygen so it was a good leaving group
and clearly the water is the h2o right
here is a weak nucleophile so if we just
went off of the checklist that we
learned about when we just explored the
differences between sn1 and sn2
reactions we probably would have
predicted an sn1 reaction here we
probably would have said the first step
would have been that this bond just
broke on its own and this guy just left
forming a carbo cation and only then
would the water the weak nucleophile
would have attacked the carbon and in
that case it could have attacked from
either side because of the all of a
sudden this wouldn't this it would lose
the it would lose its handedness this
carbon right here but everything I've
read and I've every never performed this
reaction in the chemistry lab but
everything I've read says that this is
the reaction that occurs that you
actually have this I guess you could
call it stereospecific a that you know
that you only get the trans version is
actually what predominates and actually
what is going on is an sn2 so my best
explanation is is that this is really
more of you could call it an sn2 like
reaction because it really meets the
checklist more for an sn1 in terms of
what the
reactions are but because the end
product has is actually selective you
actually end up with the trans as
opposed to both the sis and the trans
we're assuming that an sn2 type of
reaction must have occurred but I really
wanted to make this clear because it
really kind of goes against the grain of
our checklist of predicting whether an
sn1 or an sn2 reaction would occur and
the reason why at least in my mind I
think that the sn1 reaction maybe didn't
occur is in order for it to occur this
carbo cation needs to form and that
carbo cations its secondary it's not
tertiary so it's maybe just not quite
stable enough now sn1 reactions can
occur with the pox IDEs and I'll show
you two examples so if I have so if I
have let me draw two examples here so
this is ethane if I just did a double
bond here would be ethene but if I have
these bonded to an oxygen this is
ethylene ethylene this is ethylene oxide
ethylene oxide and once again if this
was an alkene it would be called either
ethene that's actually the official name
but some people call it ethylene and so
the common name for this is ethylene
actually I spelled it wrong it's
ethylene not with the ethylene ethylene
oxide I've even seen on the web a couple
of times people call this ethene oxide
which in some ways would be more
consistent so let's say on one hand we
have ethene oxide and let's say on the
other hand let's say on the other hand
we have something that looks like this
we have something that looks like this
let me try my best to draw it we have
something that looks like this and so
this this part if we just look at the
main chain you could either view this as
a propane as a propane or use the having
three carbons one two three and then a
methyl breaking off of it but this Y
shape where you have four carbons here's
usually called isobutyl so you could
call this isobutylene oxide so let's
call this isobutylene oxide that's what
you're more likely to see I so butylene
oxide and remember they just pretend
like this is a double bond does we get
the isobutylene oxide but didn't to make
it clear that it's
really not a double-bond then there's
really an oxygen in there it's really
not an alkene you put the oxide there
now let's think about the different
reactions that might occur if we have a
nucleophile in either in either
situation so if we have a nucleophile if
we have a nucleophile over here for the
ethylene oxide either of these carbons
are primary carbons so if you have a
carbon right here let me draw all of its
bonds it's bonded to one other carbon
it's bonded to a hydrogen and another
hydrogen right there so it's a primary
carbon it would not be a stable carbo
cation so in this case you would
definitely predict that an sn2 reaction
would have to occur with this epoxide
that the nucleophile the nucleophile
would attack back here and then this
electron would be taken back by the
oxygen and that would open the ring so
this was this would be an sn2 situation
and in my mind this is pretty clear but
in this situation you do have a you do
have a primary carbon right here it's
only bonded to one other carbon but over
here right over here you have a tertiary
carbon it's bonded to one two three
carbons so this would be a stable carbo
cation so in this circumstance you would
actually expect that this this epoxide
ring is so strained that the first step
is that the oxygen would just take the
electron the oxygen would just take the
electron and then you're left with
you're left with something that looks
like this let me do it in the same
colors so it's clear you would be left
with something that looks like this and
now since it took the electron just like
that or actually maybe let me make take
a step back it has to be a very good
leaving group so it wouldn't necessarily
just take the electron right there the
first step in order to make this a good
leaving group would be if you maybe had
a water around or something that it
could take a hat or some type of acid
that it could take the a hydrogen proton
from so the first step is it would take
a hydrogen proton let me do this a
little bit neater it would take a
hydrogen proton so give an electron to a
hydrogen proton
so that it becomes a good leaving group
so now our molecule looks like this do
it in the same colors our molecule will
look like that that's our carbon and now
this is an oxygen bonded to a hydrogen
and now this has a positive charge this
is now will just be a water I won't draw
it anymore and now this is an excellent
leaving group tertiary carbon this is
classic sn1 classic sn1 reaction so this
guy can essentially leave and then we
are left with we are left with down here
let me draw it over here we are left
with something that'll look like this we
have our carbon bonded not to hydrogen's
two other carbons so these are carbons
over here and then this carbon is bonded
to this Oh H we now have an alcohol and
this is now a carbo cation and now this
is ready to be attacked by even a weak
nucleophile even a weak nucleophile
could attack this so you have a tertiary
carbon in your poxy drink look for an
sn1 reaction but if you have anything
less as far as I can tell based on the
reactions that I've looked at in
multiple books if you have secondary or
primary carbons it seems like sn2 is
going to be more likely to break your
epoxide ring